das nicht die zahlen der feststellung
der unerlaubten einreise nach
deutschland an der polnischen grenze
extrem zu so wie das momentan läuft
werden die zahlen ende oktober die
3000er marke geknackt haben warum sage
ich das hier wir haben 2015 ja schon mal
ein phänomen wahrgenommen wo dieses
problem an der südgrenze an der grenze
zu österreich aufgetaucht ist spannend
sind die zahlen jetzt dass sie durch die
gleichen wie 2013 unten an der südgrenze
wo sich die ganze geschichte dann weiter
nach oben
entwickelt hat was mich umtreibt als
bundespolizist bis das ganz
offensichtlich unsere bundesregierung
derzeit sich außerstande sieht die
grenzkontrollen nach polen einzuführen
sprich zu notifizieren denn nur wenn
diese grenzkontrollen durchgeführt wird
notifiziert sind haben wir auch die
berechtigung tatsächlich
grenzpolizeiliche maßnahmen an der
grenze sozusagen an der zweiten
kontrolle linie nach europa
durchzuführen und damit holen und auch
litauen zu unterstützen nicht zu ärgern
sondern zu unterstützen und da fehlt mir
schlichtweg die entscheidungsfreudigkeit
außenministerium hier nägel mit köpfen
zu machen sozusagen wir offizieren die
grenzen von kontrollieren die migration
darum geht's kontrollierte migration
nach deutschland kann aber die ganzen zu
machen aber wir wollen das schön wissen
werden unser land ich finde es gar nicht
schwierig sich damit polen auf eine
gemeinsame aktion zu verständigen denn
die flüchtlinge kommen zum überwiegenden
teil aus weißrussland aus belarus ja sie
werden von dem weißrussischen diktator
gezielt aus dem irak eingeflogen um die
um diese migranten die flüchtlinge als
waffe gegen europa zu verwenden und
damit gegen die sanktionen die gegen ihn
verhängt worden sind die werden die die
landen in kiew werden dann in marsch
gesetzt richtung westen überwinden
dschamaat die polnisch belarussische
grenze weil die ist nicht durchgängig zu
bewachen gehen durch polen durch und
kommen dann nach deutschland und das
darf man nicht passieren lassen deshalb
bin ich vollkommen auf ihrer seite es
müssen grenzkontrollen eingeführt werden
und zwar an zwei grenzen an der
rollenspieler russischen und an der
deutsch-polnischen
und da muss man mit einem zweifachen
netz diese leute die von kiew aus in
marsch gesetzt werden auffangen denn
sonst haben wir wieder das problem es
redet ja keiner drüber das ist so eine
verdeckt geführten diskussion die zahlen
steigen und steigen und steigen es will
aber keiner mehr moment eine flüchtlings
diskussion früheren weil
koalitionsverhandlungen über klima und
sonstwas geführt werden aber darüber
muss man reden ja muss was dagegen tun
werden jetzt gerade den bundestagswahlen
dadurch mehr fragen das problem muss
auch bekannt sein warum hat man davon
nichts gehört bleiben aber das problem
gibt es seit monaten ich kann nichts
beweisen warum man darüber nicht
gesprochen hat innenministerium ich
vermute dass man damit verhindern wollte
dass eine bestimmte partei die sich auch
zur wahl gestellt hat dadurch nicht noch
mehr rückenwind natürlich die kfd und
nur so kann ich mir erklären dass das
innenministerium die bundesregierung
insgesamt also still gaal ja aber wohl
verstandenen politik sowohl der spd als
auch der cdu hätte das so formuliert
weil man muss ja wenn man so will man
muss ja den deutschen staat schützen vor
missbrauch durch durch eingeschleuste
wie soll ich denn sagen kampf migranten
die schützen
grenzkontrollen einzuführen wir ein
weiterer sargnagel
erpressen von lukaschenko warum sanktion
jähnigen wir nicht belarus warum führen
wir grenzkontrollen ein wir haben doch
gesehen in der korona zeit wie sehr und
es grenzt geschlossene grenzen wie uns
das schadet deshalb verstehe ich das gar
nicht wir würden den freiheitsgedanken
aufgeben wenn man das jetzt also
geschlossene grenzen auch in der korona
zeit da muss nicht geschadet also wenn
sie beobachtet haben wie sich damals im
frühjahr 2020 die die welle die korona
welle wie auf einer schlechten wetter
karte von südwesten über das land
gezogen hat wenn wir da nicht
tatsächlich den unnötigen reiseverkehr
unterbunden hätten dann hätten wir
dieses phänomen noch heftiger und noch
viel verbreiteter in deutschland habe
ich mir sehr sicher müssen springen
dabei dass die freiheit ist da wir schon
weg gegangen hat sie jedes mal wenn ich
jetzt pflege und dann diese ganzen
dokumente und man weiß jetzt erst wieder
was europa bedeutet was für eine
freiheit wir haben und jetzt wenn man
der reis haben hier seien seien im
dokument hier sein passt da muss man
noch so ein zettel ausfüllen nach
österreich geflogen am sonntag das kam
mir vor als würde ich nach new york
einreisen und jetzt weiß ich erst die
reisefreiheit zu schätzen aber sebastian
du hast du es denn ich muss sagen das
große versprechen von schengen war ja
wir schaffen quasi die binnengrenzen ab
und das geht einher mit dem besseren
schutz der aussengrenzen wir sehen zu
dass wir uns an der außengrenze schützen
wir sind in deutschland in so einer in
so einer situation wo man so geführt so
denkt als wäre grenzschutz an sich was
illegitim ist das ist ja nicht so
sondern der staat hat ja auch ist ja
sozusagen bezieht er seine legitimität
auch daher dass er mich schutz
beispielsweise vor beispielsweise
illegalen migranten darum eine manie
summary die hierher kamen oder so wenn
er das nicht tut gibt der staat sich
teilweise auf das darf nicht sein
also polen und ungarn geben sich
wirklich die größte mühe und der die
ver.di noch den allergrößten respekt zum
schutz der außen der europäischen
außengrenzen
in solchen situationen wie wir sie jetzt
aber haben wie sich anbahnen reicht das
nicht die kunst die kunst schlichtweg
nicht garantieren dass wir in europa
reisefreiheit haben denn der garant für
die reisefreiheit für den wegfall der
binnen grenzkontrollen in europa sind
die staaten die die außengrenzen haben
so jetzt gilt es natürlich dazu
unterstützen hopper keine frage dafür
gibt es die grenzschutzagentur frontex
aber wenn auch das jetzt in einer
gewissen phase nur sehr schleppend
vorangeht dann müssen wir zum weiteren
schutz der freiheit in europa eine
zweite kontrolle linie einziehen und das
funktioniert meiner auffassung nach nur
wenn wir an der deutsch polnischen
grenze oder auch an der deutsch
tschechischen grenze führen gewissen
zeitraum
kontrollieren da reinkommen nicht die
ganzen kontrollieren und für einen
gewissen zeitraum ich hätte sorge das
ist damit für alle zeiten schon wieder
geregelt oder freud mann und wir hätten
der eu endgültig dann den todesstunde
das tun wir nicht meint dass sie halte
ich sogar für eine für eine maßnahme um
die eu zu verteidigen so weil die
nämlich zerfällt wenn leute sehen dass
dieser diese staatengemeinschaft keine
autorität hat ihre grenzen zu schützen
also wenn lukaschenko in kiew
in großer zahl flüchtlinge in marsch
setzen kann die hier eindringen die
hierher kommen und die eigentlich kein
fluchtgrund haben jetzt sind alle
geflogen und haben die tickets bezahlt
mit der belarussischen
fluggesellschaften aus dem irak hierher
geflogen sind keine armen menschen diese
die sind auch nicht bedroht vom
hungertod und da gibt es auch moment
keinen kann keinen großartigen
bürgerkrieg vor dem die fliehen mussten
das sind im klassischen sinne
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge die möchtegern in
europa leben eine existenz gründen das
ist alles legitim aber es ist nicht das
große elend und
unglücklicherweise haben wir ja schon
einige sanktionen gegen weißrussland
verhängt da gibt es nicht mehr so
wahnsinnig viel beispielsweise ganze
europäische luftraum für die airline der
der borussen gesperrt die dürfen nicht
mal drüber fliegen die dort nicht mehr
landen so viele möglichkeiten gibt es
nicht mehr der spekuliert natürlich
darauf dass es so läuft wie im fall der
türkei da war der flüchtlings druck von
erdogan weitergereicht die übers
mittelmeer nach griechenland und dann
den balkan hoch bis sie durch österreich
hierher gekommen sind das war ja eine
politische erpressung von erdogan bis es
soweit war dass man mit ihm verhandelt
hat über über geld mit dem die lager
dort finanzier und geschenkideen wir
gemacht haben das ist lange ich bin na
ja ich war immer stolz angela merkels
bundeskanzler haben in den stolz
europäerin was wir da gemacht haben denn
die mit erdogan dafür schäme ich mich
als deutschland was ich will alles
andere die die alternative wäre gewesen
sei
anders wäre das wäre die die alternative
wäre gewesen die europäischen
binnengrenzen auf dem balkan durch
bewaffnete grenzposten zu schützen und
dann auch zu schießen das durfte nicht
sein man musste verhindern dass
überhaupt etwas mittelmeer kommen und
das hat natürlich lukaschenko genau
beobachtet der weiß wie das läuft und
dafür wartet jetzt auf das angebot der
eu aber du hast von der autorität der eu
gesprochen findest du nicht dass die
genauso bedroht ist wenn wir uns von
jemandem erpressen lassen der mit
migranten droht und sofort lassen wir
unsere idee von europa fallen wir lassen
sie im stich okay wenn jemand bedroht
ich habe ich habe eine bestimmte
persönliche erfahrung gemacht ich bin
mal von ostpreußen aus dem zug also vom
osten in den westen gefahren wieder nach
berlin durch polen durch da kommt man
durch ein das gehört ja das frühere
ostpreußen gehört ja zu russland das ist
ja eine exklave
und da fährt man mit dem zug durch ein
wald durch dann kommt man an einen zaun
der wird von grenzposten mit der hand
geöffnet stacheldraht dann fährt man
ganz langsam durch und man kommt aus
dieser russischen exklave nach polen und
sobald der zug auf der polnischen seite
aus dem wald heraus kommt sieht man dass
es europa weil die weil die landschaft
geordnet ist die sind ist bestellt von
bauern das sind über die felder sind
bestellt das sieht völlig anders aus als
auf der russischen seite das ist europa
und das müssen wir auch schützen und das
dafür hat daran vergreifen wir uns nicht
wenn wir verhindern dass flüchtlinge von
solchen diktatoren in marsch gesetzt
werden um das alles durcheinander zu
sagen was sie sich vielleicht menschen
als polizist ja also schützen es gilt
auch die menschen zu schützen die dort
staatlich organisiert nach europa
geschleust werden
der lukaschenko eröffnet mit dieser mit
dieser geschichte den schlepperbanden
tür und tor und macht dort ein markt auf
den es so in weißrussland bisher noch
nie gegeben hat die menschen die hierher
gebracht werden sind teilweise unter
lebensgefährlichen bedingungen in lkws
gefertigt jetzt heute erst wieder
gelesen in görlitz passiert gott sei
dank einer ums leben bekommen aber 25
personen in einem kleintransporter
hinten drin und das gilt es zu
unterbinden
[Musik]